let's talk about Patrick Stewart and his
love of dogs you know Captain Picard he
loves his pitbulls so much he even
shared as the screen with one who said
that number one the cod is a man with
problems and difficulties at the
beginning of this and I thought if he
had a dog at his side it would send a
message that here is somebody who needs
this creature to keep them sane but then
I said but it has to be a pity sir
Patrick's been fostering pit bulls since
2017 we went back 33 years to find our
first contact in 1987 when I was an
access that's working with the Royal
Shakespeare Company after my Saturday
afternoon mass and it was my custom to
scuttle home for tea time and Star Trek
what does it feel like seeing that video
again
it's creepy and a little embarrassing I
came here to find safety but one is
never safe from the past
Patrick is now 79 his new 10 episode
series Star Trek Picard premieres
tonight on CBS all access and he just
had this co-star reunion meeting up with
Whoopi Goldberg
I want to invite you into the second
season
[Applause]
[Music]